hi i'm gonna call this uh
time uh chit chat
and
you can always switch off because i know
that not many people are interested in
what i'm about to say
what
fascinates me is
uh the majority of aikidoka
are not interested in no senses
spiritual side
and i'm going to bounce around a bit
with my conversation
i don't know what point
i do read a lot about i sensei but i
also forget just as much
it gets very confusing some people have
got every single day detail about what i
sense he's done in his life
but i was interested
purely
in the fun i had on the map training
and the last thing i want to do is talk
about
the religious side of the spiritual side
of those senses i could own
so i should really be amazed by
people's reaction about
i'm not interested in that i just want
to know
how to perform the techniques
but to perform them
you've also got to in my
opinion
be a little bit
nutty a little bit off the wall in your
thinking
because if you just think that our
senses aikido is going to be
given to you awarded to you
by you doing good shia nagis and good
techniques
and i'm afraid that you must be more
disillusioned than than i
am all was at the time
i
have a sort of a dividing line between
choosing
about what i think of
cytosinsi
and no scentsy
but
cytosins he taught technical and he
wanted to he said he
he put his life's work to showing her
senses technical work
so that's really led us even more away
from the spiritual side of our senses
art
but we all want to be another scentsy
you know why
i did at the time
and i would imagine that most people do
they perhaps watch our senses films once
they've got into aikido after some
period they may have been drawn to
aikido because of those scentsy
films and
philosophy
there's so many different facets to what
makes us
start aikido and those who've got my
book will have read my introduction to
it and
the last thing was a martial art that i
wanted from it
anyway it got me in there and i'm still
in here now
and it's still fascinating me excuse me
the
the religious side of our sensing
i don't want to go down that track
because i don't want to start praying
and
chanting to to the gods the came as he
says
and he called upon the camera to give
him enlightenment
and this is where i'm really going
more and more people today
you may not all agree because you're
from all different religions
countries
beliefs
but
we all but i'm
having my say here and um
i'm not going to offend anybody by it
but religion seems to be dying out as
far as vast numbers of people
wanting to believe in a religion
to believe in a god
or some form of god
i have a group of
muslims i teach and
i really respect the way they
take time out
you know perhaps soon as class is
finished they'll go to a corner
and they'll all pray together
it's quite fascinating to watch them
really because i'm thinking
why are they doing that
what makes them so committed
and yet oh sensei was committed
he's his daily life wouldn't be complete
in the obama period of his life
where he
i believe
we all
understand that's where he created his
aikido
i'm not talking about techniques i'm
talking about the whole
it's a little bit like
you know we're presented with aikido as
if somebody's just presented us with a
large beautiful cake that's been made
we don't seem to be interested in
how the ingredients were formed where
did they come from the ingredients how
much trouble was it getting the
ingredients
how long did it take to make the actual
cake before it was put in the oven
people think that
um like with children
they thought the modern day child when
interviewed in the uk
thought that chips come from the
supermarkets
they didn't realize the thing called a
potato
is where chips come from
and they're not interested as long as
they get their chips
why would they need to be interested in
the potato how it's grown what species
it is
what is what makes better
chips
they just know that they like the the
thin fries the fat fries the skins on
the fries
cheesy fries chilli dip fries i mean
barbecued dip
now we can go on
the same as the different gods
you know who do we choose
well we choose the one we like
now
if you are a real firm
atheist and you don't believe in any
forms of god
then
you can only be left with the technical
side of anything
and
it's there in front of you
there's the potato
you can chip it boil it
smash it
or mash it i should say
so you have the
the chance to do with it what you wish
if it's not already
in the form of a chip
so you've already
decided by holding the potato
that you've gone back
a few stages
and this is what i
would like to talk about in this
film
i
did believe in god when i was younger
but perhaps that was because i had it
ran down my throat
and i had to believe in a god i was
brought up a catholic went to a catholic
school
where right next door was the main
largest catholic church
in the city of cambridge
so really
you know it's a one-way motorway and
you're steered down that motorway and
that's where
you
get convinced
that there is a god
and that only your religion is the right
one to follow
a little bit like the one like you know
is the only one to follow not the
aikikai
one
and yet to me the aikikai one seems
more harmonious
with keeping
friendship
flexibility
and all the beliefs that osensee wanted
somebody
to believe in
and yet iwama appears to be the place
excuse me again
i'm still getting over the remnants of
covid
after about six weeks
so forgive me for
struggling sometimes
the
um
belief
that
iwama
was the
mecca
that was where you got the fine
technical understanding of her senses
techniques
but if at the hombu dojo
the harmony the flowing the blending
perhaps that could be put more towards i
sense his
religious desires for the world to
become
a more harmonious place for people to
get on
for the world to stop fighting each
other and becoming one
none of us hope
that we will be
in the
generation where
life ends for the human race
all these dictators start pushing
the nuclear button
and then
perhaps
not anything will grow even
it will kill all vegetation as well as
living creatures
you just can't put your mind into
thinking like that can you
every single thing is destroyed
i don't know whether it's just me
believing but i'm sure that somewhere
in time
as rain falls
[Music]
and
the rain
with its nuclear waste in the atmosphere
soaks into the ground and kills
everything
i'm sure that somewhere
the earth will
survive
and some queen will come back
we won't be here to
enjoy it
i don't wish to go there in my mind and
i'm sure you don't
but there will be a generation either
hours now
or in the future
where this planet will be destroyed
by stupid ignorant
dictators
because they have the power to do it
like now
we have dictators
going to war with people who are quite
happy
to live their own life and go their own
direction
there's always been wars there's wars
ever since the first world war second
world war but there's wars going on
around the globe now somebody wants to
take over
the thing that you often hear is
well if there's a god why doesn't he do
something about it
and it proves there isn't a god because
if there was
he wouldn't let all this devastation
and lives be lost
if he really cares for us
he would save us
and also you hear
god will save us just keep believing in
him
and that's quite a hard one isn't it to
swallow god will save us
what powers will he save if i haven't
seen any
i haven't seen anything yet have you
so therefore that makes me go away from
what i call the living god believing in
the living god
spending all my life
praying to
god
who's going to come and save me come and
save the planet
when you have dictators who are here in
the physical sense
the physical
fingers to push the buttons
god
and all of those who were killed and
murdered and have gone before us in
illness or just old age
where have they gone
and this will be the next film i will be
talking about
god is not in physical form that i know
of and no one's proven it yet
so
i don't believe he can help us
physically
i only believe
perhaps mentally
but if i don't want to believe in god
then perhaps i can believe in let's say
my grandfather
if i liked my grandfather my grandmother
if i liked her
perhaps i can even stretch out
to believing in perhaps no sense he will
hear me
if i talk to him
but then i've got to start believing
that there's life after death haven't i
that makes me as big a wacko
as some
those who
don't believe that there is a god
okay
thank you for listening to my chit chat
and chit chat too
will be coming
soon